all right
[Applause]
no but they say timing is everything
I am so honored to meet your
acquaintance you know I'm not good at
hobnobbing like I'm just not I
understand we love our friends around us
and we love to keep it really tight but
not about not socializing with you know
just hanging out it's true I have
friends and they'll say like well so and
so and so and so and so and so came and
I just think oh God that sounds like a
lot you know like I'd rather kick it
with my friends who I'm so at ease with
now like complete pivot Jeffrey is he
one of your close friends well I've
never met him his real deal you're about
to celebrate 54 four years
thank you like what your first date like
will you tell me about yourself I asked
her wait that's even better what why
ever wanted to see me again I have no
idea why
why and he was at Dartmouth and he um
called we had a mutual friend and he'd
seen me walking around the campus of
Dartmouth and and he asked the friend
could he call me so he called and I
didn't know anything you know I just
knew he was a friend of the friend and
um and I thought well he's a Dartmouth
guy so he probably wants to like go to a
bar or something I'd never been to a bar
and so I just said oh let's go to this
bar Hilltop like I've been there many
times super cool I was totally cool so
we parked the car we walk in and there
are two big guys at the door and they
they go and I said what was that I
didn't understand what they were saying
and finally Jeffrey said they want they
want your ID I said to him what's that I
had no idea what I do that I needed fake
ID to get into a bar when I was 16. and
what happened well we turned around and
left and I said so many years later I
said to him what did you think like why
would you want to take me out again he
said I thought you needed taken care of
which is so sweet
[Music]
I mean is it true that he sends you love
texts he does and sometimes they go
astray how so he sent them to the wrong
person
and what a chance do they say my dear
friend who's also my public says he he
sent a text to her and and he meant it
for me and he said you're going to be
delicious tonight
[Applause]
I don't think this was meant for me
did she turn like bright or bad I didn't
see it but I imagine so I mean women
love you kids love you adults love you
and you are one gay icon
do you
I mean how do you process that
I don't I don't even know what to say I
know I didn't even know how to ask the
question when I started 20 years ago I
think um I mean certainly there were
shows that had gay people in it but they
were gay people in it you know it wasn't
that they were just a friend and oh by
the way they happened to be gay it was
their my friends are you know
summer straight some are gay who cares
yeah and and I just invited my friends
so uh maybe that was something that made
them feel connected to the show and
someone
all right so you were a pilot when
Jeffrey and I first got married we lived
in North Carolina I was still in college
and across the um Street was a a small
airport and so I went across the street
and I found the people who had the pot
you know were training pilots and I said
I'd like to learn how to fly a plane and
they said to me I'm sorry we won't teach
we don't have anybody here that would
teach a woman how to fly an airplane and
what was your response well then find
somebody
and they found somebody's in the next
town
I don't know why I mean I just was like
well that's not the answer and one time
you were on a Runway so the helicopter
something about a last flight maybe I
don't know that was my last slide but I
was landing and what you had what you
had I didn't realize you had to do is
ask for permission for a taxiway so I
landed and I just made a right turn onto
a taxiway and right in front of me was a
helicopter fortunately the helicopter
had its rotor going and the helicopter
went like that and I went right
underneath
and I could hear the tower go student
pilot
[Applause]
well you have so many loving fans around
the world and we have a few people who
wanted to ask you some burning questions
is it okay if we reveal the first one
sure okay roll the tape please hi Aina
hi Drew you and I are going to Paris
we've been promising each other this for
a long time now and I want to know what
would be the first restaurant that you
would take me to
on our first night in Paris
no Jeffrey and Keith are not with us
it's a girls weekend we are very very
certain about that
I love you
I love you too much well where would you
take her to Paris on Nightwing there's a
wonderful restaurant in Paris called
Lulu which is in the in the Louvre well
I think that Juliana would love that
that sounds like the perfect setting
Aina in Paris oh my God
[Music]
foreign